moi je suis arrivé en 2004 le groupe il
existait il existait depuis on va dire
99 2000 mais pour de vrai sur les sur
scène depuis depuis 2001 2002 quoi c'est
un groupe qui tournait voilà quand je
suis arrivé dans le groupe ça tournait
ça commence à tourner bien depuis un an
ou deux les Fatals Picards un groupe qui
conjugue humour et musique avec des
textes engagés traversant différents
styles musicaux ils empruntent tantôt
open
musical particuliers par rapport par
rapport au groupe étant donné que le
disons que le cahier des charges dont
des Fatals Picards c'est plus de la
musique humoristique donc en fait après
la musique dépendra du texte choisi il y
a des chansons un petit peu pro et
degrés qui voilà qui qui sont bien avec
une musique un petit peu plus rock un
petit peu plus punk il y a des il y a
des textes un petit peu plus on va dire
sensible ou nostalgique mais qui vont
plus avec une orchestration un peu plus
chanson française
parlons-en de la chanson française en
2007 et les musiciens représentent
l'Hexagone au concours de l'Eurovision
avec l'amour à la française
se produiront le 20 octobre sur la scène
de la break blouse à Bois-d'Arcy le
groupe HF sa deuxième année de tournée
pour l'album coming out avant de sortir
un nouvel opus en 2013 la scène devient
une zone test pour de nouveaux morceaux
d'incorporer dans notre répertoire des
nouvelles chansons qu'on va sortir
l'année prochaine pour voir un petit peu
quelle est la réaction du public voir si
c'est là on va pouvoir les exploiter
cyniquement parce que on s'est rendu
compte au fil du temps qu'il y a des
chansons qui fonctionnent très bien en
disent qui est moins bien sur scène et à
l'inverse c'est pareil quoi donc voilà
ce qu'on va voir à Bois-d'Arcy c'est ça
c'est beaucoup de chansons de notre
dernier album enfin beaucoup de chansons
des trois derniers on va piocher un peu
dans le répertoire beaucoup plus vieux
mais de manière un petit peu plus
anecdotique et puis quelques nouvelles
chansons quelques nouveautés voilà qu'on
commence à jouer donc ils sont qui sont
on va dire qui sont qui sont frais mais
qui sont peut-être pas aussi carrés que
les trucs qu'on joue depuis 10 ans quoi
c'est ça